[Musica]
grazie mille
così parliamo di incontri
provate un attimo pensare a questo
semplice gesto che facciamo quando
incontriamo altre persone
il saluto si pensano anche il saluto il
gesto del saluto abbia origini profonde
nella storia della nostra evoluzione
sociale e chi abbia il significato di
attirare l'attenzione sulla mastro sulla
nostra ma non vota e disarmata a segno
della nostra nelle nostre buone
intenzioni
questo gesto significherebbe proprio
guarda non voglio farti del male infatti
non userò la mia mano lo strumento più
potente che possiedo per danneggiarci a
pensarci bene la mano è davvero uno
strumento o meglio un organo
straordinario lo scrittore austriaco
heinz fischer ha scritto che la mano è
il vero organo della spinta iniziano e
dell'evoluzione umana grazie alla mano
infatti erano stai scrivere siamo usciti
dalla ri storia e sulla mano si basano
la nostra milano e le nostre interazioni
con la società sono infatti tantissime
le azioni che facciamo con le nostre
mani appunto dirci 10 utilizzare pensi
anche a lavorare con i bambini
migliorano
questo è particolarmente vero per noi
italiani che abbiamo fatto
tesi stimolare un arte che spesso in via
ea volte
in giro con le mani esprimiamo
sentimenti
pensate alla dolcezza di una cresta
prima giochiamo lottiamo con le mani
esprimiamo gli stessi creano arte
suoniamo strumenti indicati che appunto
sono tantissime le espressioni figurate
che hanno a che fare con la mano a dare
una mano oppure avere in mano vittoria
oppure stanze regole mani ma dicevo
l'anno è un organo estremamente
importante e possiamo predire che sulla
che la nostra mano è il ponte che si
connette resto del mondo che ci permette
di sm spettatori anni tra lo stesso
perché non riscontrarlo provate per un
attimo a pensare a come potrebbe essere
una nostra giornata dalla mattina quando
risvegliate alla sera quando la di
dormire passata senza poter usare le
nostre mani e che è così vero
eppure sono tantissime le persone che a
causa di devastanti condizioni mediche
perdono la vita il dall'ara domani
pensate alle geniali alytus
all'istruzione muscolare e questa lista
la purtroppo è ancora molto lunga un dio
che verterà invita ad usare le mani si
valuterà di intesa l'arresto dell'uomo
non so spesso perde la propria
dipendenza e con questa sete di perdere
pure la prevendita si sente meno amato
professore della pretty in un bellissimo
attento che ha detto una cosa che è
anche lavoro fondamente lui sostiene
traduzione mia che attivo è un essere
umano non può mai essere il meno amato
piuttosto sostiene che l'ambiente
artificiale di ci circonda ad essere
fermato che è la tecnologia a destra e
una categoria è inadeguata alle
necessità 20 tv che ne dovrebbero
beneficiare lui
inoltre sostenere che attraverso
innovazione detto no li potremmo un
giorno trascendere la risalita non so
voi ma mica li fanno un effetto davvero
potente e hanno cambiato drasticamente
il mio modo di pensare fin da quando
sono bambino sono sempre stato lì
entusiasta nei confronti della
tecnologia che per me ha sempre avuto
l'unico senso di renderci la vita
migliore col tempo questa mia passione
si è trasformata nel desiderio di dare
contributo e nella speranza che in
futuro non si parli più di disabilità
durante i miei studi da ingegnere
meccanico e medico e infine robotico e
anche grazie alle tante ore passate a
giocare ai videogiochi a guardare film
mi sono appassionato ai cosiddetti
esoscheletri potenziati e non sono
sicuramente il solo in questa sala che
era mai sentito parlare
questi dispositivi sono dei veri e
propri robot da indossare che aumentano
le capacità motorie e la forza delle
persone che li indossa la mia non è una
passione originale evitato
nuova pensate che il primo brevetto di
un esoscheletro potenziato risale
nientemeno che alla fine del 1800 questo
che vedete è il primo tentativo di
realizzarne uno datato al 1965 da parte
della general electric per stessa
ammissione del tè razionalità non è
stato però è successo però è stato un
trampolino di lancio estremamente
importante per i 50 anni sono passati
dalla questo primo tentativo e più di
cento dal primo brevetto è sicuro che in
questo tempo ricercato nei tecnici di
tutto il mondo hanno lavorato
incessantemente e allo sviluppo di
questi dispositivi e sono stati fatti
letteralmente passi da gigante
il termine esoscheletro potenziato fa
pensare a una specie di ossatura o
corazza esterna al nostro corpo
alimentata una qualche contenere
miliardi di sostiene questi dispositivi
si basano su materiali reader i pattini
e allo fibre composite la fibra di
carbonio appunto e sono alimentati dai
potenti motori elettrici che servono per
sostenere il peso per l'esoscheletro
stesso e della persona che lo indossa e
facile pensare
questi dispositivi in una catena di
montaggio ad aiutare operai a sollevare
i carichi pesanti per evitare infortuni
ed è quello per cui vengono utilizzati
in uno stabilimento della bmw grazie
agli ato scheletri di esser bionic però
non è altrettanto intuitivo almeno per
me pensare che volerli indossare uno per
essere di nuovo in grado di abbracciare
una persona cara senza avere paura di
stritolarlo perlomeno di terrorizzarla
seguendo questo stesso concetto da
qualche anno è diventato popolare di
lean di utilizzare materiali morbidi
come strutture l'interfaccia tra i
sistemi
che significa banalmente i motori e
l'uomo linea è quella di trasformare
queste zoe scheletri in passati di
nervosismo e zoe muscoli ovvero
strutture muscolari esperta nel nostro
corpo è in grado di muovere i nostri
hardy anche palco sto dei muscoli veri e
propri e limitato sono robot meno
modelli è vero ma molto più sicuri e
confortevoli della controparte rigida
questo è un esempio per farvi capire
quello di cui sto parlando
questo è un cosiddetto esoscheletro
morbido abbiamo lavorato durante il
dottorato mentre ero a singapore
in pratica è una maglietta dove vengono
fatti passare dei capi che chiamiamo
tendine artificiali attraverso il
tessuto che sono collegati a dei motori
che come avete visto sono posizionati
dietro la schiena per la persona che lo
indossa quando questi motori vengono
attivati chi erano questi cavi e sono in
grado di muovere gli arti superiori e
quindi possibile rimuovere il telaio
quella parte visita che caratterizza gli
esoscheletri dirette reggi che appunto è
mai possibile fare a meno anche dei
motori per lo meno di quelli
convenzionali nel paiolo ruote slam per
l'università di harvard hanno lavorato
al progetto di un robot indossabile
berlano che chiamiamo per i bravi in
questo robot non ci sono motori metalli
e infatti quando si indossa si ha la
sensazione di indossare un sentitissimo
40 è fatto infatti di tessuti e di
camere d'aria sottilissime che vengono
inserite in specialità scherer esatte
sopra le dita quando queste camere
d'aria vengono personalizzate in quanto
sia attiva ed è in grado di muovere la
mano della persona che lo indossa
si può dire che i tessuti sono i motori
che quando si attivano sipre spesa lo
sono in grado di aprire e chiudere le
nostre dita in fase di costruzione
possiamo letteralmente programmare in
questi tessuti a comportarsi come
vogliamo
la seconda poi quale camera d'aria
chiediamo di attivare possiamo aprire o
chiudere la mano della persona che lo
indossa
dicevo presso l'esa e quindi sono un
robot il mio marco e per attivarlo serve
della semplice aria compressa non solo
un po mettere in contatto con il corpo
questa tecnologia si permette di
abbassare drasticamente i vostri di
materiali per fabbricare un robot
i partiti si serve semplicemente tessuti
e camere d'aria invece che acciaio o
firma di carbonio
inoltre abbattiamo drasticamente oppure
i costi della tecnologia riserve del
fabbricato
pensate che invece di utilizzare prese
al controllo numerico torni tra la
colonna utilizziamo ma e devo dire che
la cosa che è straordinario che per me
perché quando mi sono iscritto a
ingegneria mi sarei mai davvero
spiritato di per imparare a usare
macchine da cucire in questo momento è
in corso uno studio pilota con volontari
al pettine adesioni spiani preventivo di
questo studio è di dimostrare che il
nostro quanto è in grado utilizzare
queste persone ad essere di nuovo in
grado di manipolare oggetti di uso
comune
grazie infatti a questo incontro tra
armonica e tessuti
siamo grandi culture un dispositivo
leggerissimo sicuro tendenzialmente a
basso costo
il nostro scopo è quello di restituire
indipendenza a queste persone e vi
assicuro che non c'è nulla che ripari le
ore trascorse i laboratori l'impegno
come la bella sensazione che da poter
aiutare queste persone soprattutto
quando in cambio ti rispondo
non so dire come questo vorrei chiudere
con una riflessione ancora c'è molta
strada da fare prima di colmare la
mancanza di questo ambiente artificiale
che ci circonda però spero che con
questa chiacchierata di anche convinti
che si può guarire la tecnologia
io sono convinto che per farlo servono
due passi il primo innalzare il nostro
livello di educazione alla tecnologia
stessa attraverso l'istruzione la
ricerca e la divulgazione e il secondo e
abbassando nella complessità quindi per
esempio utilizzando tessuti e macchine
da cucire per fare robot invece che
metalli e 12 nei mercati che la
tecnologia può davvero abbattere quelle
barriere che oggi ci sembrano
insormontabili
io credo che la tecnologia potrà davvero
prenderci tutti uguali grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]